You should take care of this child
Unoze No. 4 Once you've shown mercy
, you should take care of him until he becomes independent.I'm a
reindeer.
We shouldn't live alone Didn't I
tell
you I'm not telling you to love your enemies
But we're loved by our neighbors We're the
ones who lend a cane to those who don't know where to go We were
loved because we wanted  Isn't that it?
It's like both you and I are cursed
Curses and blessings are essentially the same Lindell, it's up to you
how you take it.
Heh, I don't know, but you're probably busy Ren says you're going to get wrinkled on 4,
so from
now on, you're an acquaintance
of
mine.  I
don't think your
name is
good, so what should I do?
No one in the world
looks back on you Even if you're panting in pain, sadness and loneliness, they're always watching over you
Aisin and save yourself
[music]
me
meri se
[music]